otro retroceso para el derecho al aborto
en Estados Unidos El juez Federal
Matthew nominado por Donald Trump
revirtió la aprobación del uso de la
mifeprisstona una píldora para la
interrupción del embarazo el medicamento
cuenta con la aprobación de la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos conocida como fda por sus
siglas en inglés la medida prohíbe el
acceso al fármaco al que las mujeres
acudieron en mayor medida tras la
reversión por parte de la Corte Suprema
del fallo Rose versus weight que
protegía la interrupción del embarazo a
nivel Federal la vicepresidenta
estadounidense kamala Harris dijo que la
decisión amenaza a los derechos de las
mujeres
diré que no hay duda de que el
presidente y yo apoyamos a las mujeres
de Estados Unidos y haremos todo lo
posible para garantizar que las mujeres
tengan la capacidad de tomar decisiones
sobre su salud reproductiva de la manera
que ellas lo necesitan y eso lo deciden
ellas no su gobierno
el juez dictó el fallo sobre la
hipótesis de fda ignoró los riesgos que
podría representar la ingesta del
medicamento la fda pasa por alto
legítimas preocupaciones de seguridad en
violación de su deber estatutario
basándose en un razonamiento claramente
sin fundamentos y en estudios que no
apoyaban sus conclusiones no obstante la
implementación está en espera pues llegó
casi al mismo tiempo que el juez Thomas
alrights nominado por Barack Obama
ordenó lo contrario e instruye a las
autoridades estadounidenses al no hacer
cambios que restrinjan el acceso al
medicamento en los 17 estados que los
demócratas han protegido el derecho al
aborto tras la reversión de versus wait
la bife pistola fue aprobada por la fda
en el año 2000